Uh,
well,
good,
good.
It's,
it's so nice to see you
again on this gorgeous,
gorgeous autumn day.
And we had a wonderful,
wonderful weekend.
Didn't win.
Yes,
we did.
Uh,
okay.
Today
I want us to begin.
We move ahead.
We're moving ahead.
Today we begin with Mr John Locke.
Put the next three classes,
Mr. Lock.
It is hard to believe that a little
book like this in this not terribly
distinguished addition mind you,
but nevertheless in this edition of
just pissed over a hundred pages,
did a book of this length could
have such world shaping effects.
If anyone would ever doubt
the importance of ideas,
political ideas in history.
Uh,
I would only say to you to consult the
history and the influence of John Locke.
A remarkable,
uh,
I want to talk today a
little bit about Mr Locke.
John Locke is for our purposes today.
I mean,
there are many reasons
why one would read him in,
in,
in different kinds of classes.
But for our purposes,
uh,
John Locke gives the modern state,
the expression that is
most familiar to us.
Uh,
his writings seem to have been so
completely absorbed and adopted by Thomas
Jefferson when he wrote the
declaration of independence.
That lock seems to have
become virtually a,
a kind of honorary,
a founding father,
as it were of,
of America.
Uh,
among other things,
uh,
John Locke advocates,
the natural liberty and equality of
human beings are natural rights to such
things as life,
liberty,
and what he calls estate or property.
Uh,
the idea that government,
at least legitimate government
is government by consent.
Uh,
that legitimate government
is necessarily limited,
uh,
in,
limited government constituted
by a separation of powers.
And that when governments become
repressive or that when governments become
abusive of natural rights,
uh,
that the people have
a right to revolution.
Uh,
in addition to this,
John Locke,
a,
it was a famous,
uh,
advocate of religious toleration.
Uh,
his name is forever linked with our
ideas today of what we might call liberal
or,
or constitutional democracy.
He gives the modern constitutional state.
It's,
again,
it's definitive and in many ways,
most familiar expression.
Yeah,
lock did not arise.
X Nilo is nor did anyone.
Locke's writings come from some
somewhere and from some source.
They were prepared in many ways in
part by Machiavelli who had died
approximately a century before locks,
birth,
but more importantly by another English
writer or by an English writer with whom
we have spent some time.
Namely Mr. Hobbs.
Thomas Hobbes,
Hobbes Tuck,
Machiavelli's idea of the prince and
in effect turned it into a theory or
doctrine of sovereignty.
The Hobbs,
he in sovereign,
is it the basis of our,
of our idea?
Is it impersonal or what we might
call representative government?
Uh,
he transforms princely rule.
Hobbes does into an office into,
uh,
an,
an an office call.
The sovereign and this
office is for Hobbes.
The creation of a social contract or
covenant is he calls it responsible to the
agents or persons who
have created the contract.
Hobbes had taught that the sovereign is
representative of the people who create
his office in order to ensure peace,
justice,
and order.
Without the power of the sovereign,
we would find ourselves
in a condition of nature,
a state of nature term coined by hubs
to indicate a world without civil
authority or at least with
only week civil authority,
unable to enforce common rules and laws.
Hobbs gave voice to the
doctrine of secular absolutism,
one that invests the sovereign with
absolute power to do whatever is necessary
to ensure again,
the rule of law,
justice and political stability.
And out of these rather harsh,
uh,
and formidable premises,
lock created,
uh,
a different,
what we wouldn't meet think of is a more
liberal constitutional theory of the
state.
Okay.
Why?
Being still in many ways very dependent
on the premises that that hubs again,
modifying Machiavelli had,
had undertaken
lock,
set out a process of domestication.
He set out,
he set out to tame or to domesticate
Hobbes is fierce or harsh theory of
absolute government,
which had found few
defenders in his own day,
uh,
locks.
Most important book political,
at least his most important
work of political theory
of political philosophy is
his two treatises of civil government,
of which we are only reading the second
the book we have before us is called
this often simply referred
to as the second treatise.
But you will probably have suspected,
I think that the second treatise
was proceeded by a first treat us.
The first treatise is much longer
than the second treatise and it was an
elaborate and painstaking one could
almost say deconstruction of the theory of
the divine right of kings,
which in his era,
uh,
had received a expression by a man
named Robert filmer whose name appears.
I think occasionally in the second
treatise filmer had written a book called
Patriarchy.
And the Patriarchy had argued that,
uh,
all political authority derives from the
grant of authority that God had given
to Adam.
And therefore that all legitimate
authority has divine right behind it.
Locks first treatise is a very important,
but also I have to say extremely tedious
work and you should be grateful that I
am not assigning it to,
but it's at a very interesting
book in its own right of,
of in many ways biblical
criticism and exposition.
But it's only in the second treatise,
uh,
that locks set out to,
set out his own positive
theory of government.
Is it worth this book was written.
Uh,
we now believe shortly before the famous
wig revolution of 1,688 and in a lock
sets out his theory of a parliamentary
supremacy rule of law and constitutional
government lock was,
I mean,
to put it maybe slightly oddly
lock was in his day to some degree,
what Aristotle was to his,
the second treatise is
intended as a practical book.
Uh,
it was a book addressed not so much
to the philosophers of his age,
but to Englishman written to them in
the everyday language of their time.
Uh,
he wrote to capture in a way
the common sense of his time.
Uh,
although this is not to say lock was not
at the same time a deeply controversy,
we'll figure lock had the
ability and it's a very,
uh,
desirable ability to take in many ways
radical or even revolutionary ideas and
express them in a kind of language that
makes people believe that this is what
they had thought all along.
And that is to some degree the
genius of the second treatise.
Uh,
in many ways that is it easier for
easier for us because locks language has
become,
for us the kind of,
I would almost take common sense or
shorthand language for the way we think
about politics.
And it was again,
his,
a mark of his genius to be able to create
that language and give it a stamp that
seemed to make people believe that this
is what they had simply been thinking
all along.
Lock was himself a deeply political man,
but he was also at the same
time as I've just been hinting,
perhaps a very reticent one.
Uh,
he lived in a period of intense,
uh,
religious and political conflict.
Uh,
he was just a boy,
a school in school.
When a King Charles the first,
uh,
was executed and he was an adult.
When another King James the second,
uh,
was overthrown and forced into exile,
a lock lived.
I mean,
he was a container,
a younger contemporary of Hobbs,
but he lived in a period of immense civil
conflict and war lock spent many years
at Oxford where he was both a student
and a fellow and he was suspected,
uh,
throughout much of his time there of
harboring a radical political sympathies,
but he was so cautious and
careful and expressing them.
They,
after many years,
even those closest to him,
uh,
we're unclear as to
what his opinions were.
The master of locks own residential
college at Oxford Bailey all college
described Mr Lock as the master of tasks.
Aternity.
Okay.
Um,
master of tasked Aternity
because he could not discover,
uh,
through questioning and so on.
Locks,
locks,
opinions on religious
and political matters.
Just think of that.
There used to be a very wonderful bust of,
of lock,
uh,
in the,
in the lobby of the British arts centre.
And I used to recommend to students when
they were down in that part of campus
to stop in and look at his look at his
face because as with Machiavelli or
there's the face is very revealing.
A,
and I used to ask people to see,
do you,
do you detect in here the sense of tat,
the master of tasks to eternity?
That was so,
uh,
that is that his college
master ahead and disgust lock,
uh,
was a private secretary in a physician
to a man named Anthony Ashley Cooper.
Uh,
later,
uh,
known as large Shaftsbury.
Uh,
Shaftsbury had a circle,
the Shaftsbury circle of,
of political followers who were opponents
of the monarchy and who were forced
into exile in 1683 lock
followed them into exile.
He spent several years in Holland,
uh,
in 1683 before returning to England
again shortly before the wid revolution
where his book,
uh,
the second treatise was published and
where he lived until his death in 1704,
just two years ago.
In fact,
Yale at the Beinecke library
held a major conference,
uh,
in commemoration of the 300th
anniversary of the death of Mr Lock.
So those are a few things about
his contributions and his context.
I want to begin today,
uh,
the substantive part of this talk by
focusing on the theme that in many ways
forms the central core of locks,
a political doctrine,
his theory of natural law.
This is a term that has
come up from time to time.
There is no modern thinker,
uh,
that I'm aware of who makes a natural law,
is important to his doctrine.
Uh,
as does lock.
The best way to observe the working or
to reconstruct the working of natural law
is to follow a procedure
that we have seen before.
To think about what is
the condition of nature,
the state of nature,
where we can see the natural
law in its operative form.
The state of nature before lock in many
ways as for Hobbs is not a condition of
ruling and being ruled
as it is for Aristotle.
The state of nature is
not a political condition.
Lock describes the state of nature
is a condition of perfect freedom.
Well,
Aristotle said that we were by nature,
members of a family,
a Polis,
a moral community of some kind,
bound by ties of civic
or family obligation lock
understands by the state of
nature a condition without civil
authority or civil obligations.
The state of nature is not for
him and historical condition,
although he does,
uh,
occasionally,
right referred to uh,
the vast tracts of North America as,
uh,
suggesting,
W I a condition of nature,
but the state of nature is a
kind of thought experiment.
What is human nature like?
Uh,
in the absence of authority,
the state of nature,
Locke suggests to us is not in a
moral condition as it was for Hobbes.
It is not simply a condition of war of
all against all the state of nature.
He tells us,
isn't in fact a moral condition.
It is governed by a moral law or a
natural law that dictates piece and socio
ability.
There is a moral law of nature that
determines that no one should harm another
person in their life,
liberty or possessions.
This law,
this natural law lock
affirms Willis Willis,
the piece in preservation of all mankind.
So the natural condition
for Loc is a moral state,
one in which a natural law
again dictates the peace,
peace into preservation.
It is not a war of all against all locks.
Natural law in some ways seems like
a very traditional form of moral law.
Familiar to readers of his time.
Readers who would have been familiar
with the natural law tradition.
Going back to Cicero,
uh,
the Roman stoics,
Saint Thomas Aquinas,
and in Locke's own day,
uh,
an important,
Anglican,
a divine by the name of Richard Hooker.
Locke's theory of moral law or natural
law sounds comforting and traditional.
And to some degree it is.
All civil authority has its foundation.
In a law of reason that is knowable by
virtue of our rational capacities alone.
The law of nature declares
according to Locke,
that we are all in his famous war term,
the workmanship of one omnipotent in
infinitely wise maker and his product of
divine workmanship.
We are never to harm
anyone in their lives.
Liberties or possessions lock again
seems to effortlessly weave together the
stoic tradition of natural law with these
Christian ideas of divine workmanship
into one seamless hole.
You can see the way in which locks
rhetoric here and his writing brings,
brings together a different strands
of the philosophical and theological
tradition.
Weaving them together in a kind of,
uh,
effortless,
whole,
almost.
Do not be simply seduced by
this because even within,
why do I say that?
Because even within the same paragraphs,
locks natural law,
the law that again,
mandates or dictates piece
and preservation of all
mankind turns into a right of
self preservation
from the beginning.
You have to say,
it is not altogether clear even whether
the natural law is a theory of moral
duty duties that we have to preserve,
uh,
others duties and obligations.
Or is it,
or whether it is a theory of natural
rights that mandates that the highest
priority be given to individual self
preservation and whatever is necessary to
achieve the preservation
of the individual.
The state of nature is a
condition without civil authority.
The law of nature,
in other words,
has no person or office to oversee,
uh,
it's enforcement or its application.
So the state of nature that he wants
describes our early describes in the book
as a condition of peace
and mutual distrust.
Quickly degenerate,
sinned,
do a condition of civil war or of war
where every individual serves as the
judge,
jury,
and executioner of the natural law,
the state of nature
quickly becomes quickly,
becomes a hobby and condition,
uh,
of essentially every man for himself.
Consider the following passage in
section 11 of the second treatise,
the damn unified person,
uh,
lock rights.
Someone who has been mistreated
in the condition of nature,
the damn defied person who's been
injured or mistreated has this power of
appropriating to himself the
goods or services of the,
of the offender by the right of self
preservation as every man has a power to
punish the crime to
prevent it being committed.
Again by the right he has of preserving
all mankind in doing all reasonable
things he can in order to that end.
In other words,
uh,
if you feel,
or if you have been wronged or feel you
have been wronged in the individual,
in the state of nature,
you have according to the
natural law of for Locke,
the right to as he puts it
appropriate to yourself,
the goods or services of the offender.
And you have that too to take from them,
uh,
their,
their goods,
their property,
their services in some way,
uh,
whatever you feel,
appropriate.
Uh,
as again,
the person who has suffered
some kind of wrong,
uh,
every person becomes,
is it worth judge and
executioner of the law of nature,
the fundamental law of nature.
Locke says,
here is the right of self preservation
in this states that each person is
empowered to do again,
whatever is in his power
to preserve him or herself.
Again,
consider the following in section 16
and one may destroy a man
who makes war upon him,
may destroy another who makes war upon
you or has discovered an enmity to his
being for the same reason that he may
kill a wolf or a lion because such men are
not under the ties of
the common law of reason.
They have no other rule,
but that of force and violence.
So also they may be
treated as beasts of prey,
those dangerous or noxious creatures that
we'll be sure to destroy him whenever
he falls into their power.
Listen to that language.
Uh,
from an original moral condition
where we are under a natural law,
not to harm others.
Uh,
a law to preserve and protect the
wellbeing of others of our kind.
We have become like lions
and wolves to each other,
beasts of prey and
other noxious creatures.
What is the state of nature?
But Eh,
in,
in the words of Dorothy,
Gale Lions,
tigers and bears,
oh my,
uh,
this is what we are to one another.
This is what I've come
to think of his locks,
Beastie airy.
And in fact,
the second treatise is rife with language
of comparing human beings to and our
behavior to animals.
He speaks about lions
and wolves elsewhere.
He speaks about polecats and
skunks and foxes and all this.
How,
if,
if in fact we are all beings as he says,
created under a natural law week.
We seem to quickly degenerate into,
into be almost be steel,
uh,
behavior,
beasts of prey,
far from being cooperative and peace,
peace seeking creatures.
Uh,
the very freedom that such beings as
ourselves enjoy in the state of nature
leads us to abuse that
freedom and in turn requires,
or is it the basis of the
need for civil government.
Okay.
However,
in the meantime,
the question that any reader of the
second treatise has to ask of themselves,
and I hope you put this forward in your,
in your sections to one another,
is whether the natural condition is lock,
understands it is one overseen by a moral
law of justifying or sanctifying peace
and security,
or whether Hobbes is,
uh,
excuse me,
lock state of nature is simply
a thinly veiled description,
a thinly papered over description of
the Hobbs Ian War of all against all was
lock,
uh,
simply hubs in some way
in sheep's clothing.
You remember his famous test?
Aternity
lock seems to be speaking
to very different languages.
In other words,
one of traditional natural law
that holds out duties to others,
uh,
as primary and the other in some ways
a modern hubs and conception of natural
rights that maintains the priority,
uh,
of right and each individual's
right to self preservation is lock.
In other words,
uh,
and this is perhaps more of an
historical than a theoretical question,
is lock a member of the ancient in
some ways sis Aronian and Tom Mystic
tradition of natural law or a modern hubs.
Ian,
do his politics derived from a theological
conception of divine workmanship or
an ultimately you might say naturalistic,
a conception or account of the human
passions and the struggle for survival.
Do his priorities go to duties or two
rights or is lock simply confused?
Is he confusing two different languages
or is he being intentionally ambiguous
in his account?
A recent book,
uh,
by a well known scholar,
of lock,
uh,
his argued I think quite
powerfully in some ways.
The,
the idea that locks idea of equality,
uh,
in the state of nature,
specifically relies upon a certain kind
of Christian theological context of
argument locks statement in paragraph
four of the second treatise,
uh,
his statement that,
there being nothing more evident than it
creatures of the same species and rank
promiscuously born to all
the same advantages of nature
should also be equal to
one and other.
That walks statement that creatures of
the same species and rank should be equal
to one another.
This is said to rely upon and dependent
upon a very specific religious argument,
what it means to belong to a species
and why belonging to the same species
confers a special rank or dignity,
uh,
on each of its members only makes sense
according to this recent interpretation
if you believe or if it is believed that
the species in question has this moral
relation to God.
The question I think
is whether locks,
idea of equality in the state of nature
or his idea of the moral law in the
state of nature relies upon this belief
or whether it can be inferred from such
things as uh,
the basic principles of freedom.
Whether this can be inferred as it
were from purely a non theological
naturalistic premises or grounds lock
to be short is silent in the second
treatise about the theological
foundations of his position,
there are no discussions of important
theological figures such as Jesus or Saint
Paul or the New Testament,
at least in the second treatise.
He discusses these issues
at length elsewhere.
These may be in some way thought
of as background considerations.
But the question remains,
I think for us,
whether these are deeply
embedded in Locke's arguments
about divine workmanship,
uh,
or whether or not that language of divine
workmanship simply serves as a kind of
window dressing,
again,
for a purely secular,
naturalistic theory,
uh,
of,
of human nature and political authority.
Very important issue.
Uh,
I think in,
in coming to understand
lock and indirectly,
uh,
very important for how we come
to think of the American regime.
Because I'll just say simply as a kind
of footnote to what I've been saying,
uh,
if lock,
is thought of in some
ways as his doctrine,
as being in some ways at the,
uh,
founding principles of the American
regime declaration of independence,
most notably,
it becomes very important.
Uh,
it becomes part of a
contemporary public argument.
Whether those foundations,
uh,
oh,
their authority to some kind
of theological doctrine,
uh,
as Jefferson costs it.
In the opening of the declaration,
the laws of nature and nature's God seems
in some way to have a kind of locking
and overtones to it.
Does do our founding doc documents
imply a theology of some kind,
the laws of nature and nature's God,
or are those principles,
again,
purely of a naturalistic,
secular kind that can do
without theology altogether?
Uh,
that,
that is an argument,
um,
uh,
a kind of scholarly and
academic argument to be sure,
but it spills over,
uh,
into,
many of our public debates over the role
or place of religion in public life.
Whenever we talk about issues
of the appropriateness of a,
of school issues like
school prayer or the,
should the 10 commandments be,
uh,
publicly displayed in,
in,
in courthouses or another
in other public places?
Or if you want to take
another famous Jeffersonian,
uh,
position,
is there a kind of absolute firewall,
a wall of separation between religion and,
and,
and to this state,
these issues,
uh,
that we very much a work work
on today and think about are,
you can see deeply embedded in how we
think about Locke and those opening
sections of the second treatise dealing
with natural law in the state of nature.
So you can see again how these ideas
penetrate deeply into the marrow of our
public or political culture.
Are we so different?
Have we become so different?
Uh,
we'll people living 300 years from now
think of us as so different and our
public debates so different from those
that animated the public issues in the
time of,
of John Locke.
Maybe not.
Maybe we aren't that different.
So,
okay.
Enough for contemporary,
let me go,
go back to Mr. Lock.
Uh,
the core of Locke's theory of
natural law in the state of nature.
Okay.
Is arguably lodged in
his account of property.
Yeah.
Chapter five of the second treatise.
If you remember anything
about lock after this class,
remember chapter five,
it is by all accounts,
maybe chapter 19 as well,
the theory of revolution,
but chapter five kind of property,
certainly in many ways,
one of the most characteristic
doctrines of Lockian political thought.
Okay.
Locke's view of human nature is that
we are very much the property acquiring
animal.
Aristotle had said we
were political by nature.
Locke says we are
property acquiring beings,
our claims to property
derived from our work.
Okay.
The fact that we have expended our labor,
our work,
something gives us a title to it.
Labor confers value and is
the source of all the values.
The state of nature is a condition he
tells us of communal ownership with Karl.
Marx would have called
primitive communism.
The state of nature is given to all men
and common Locke says it only becomes
parts only of it become private property.
Only when we add our labor to something,
let me read a famous formula in sections
20 from sections 27 and 28 every man
Locke says his property in his person.
This nobody has any right to but himself.
We all in other words have a certain Ph.
We come into the world with a certain
private property property in our person.
No one else has a right to that.
The Labor of his body block continues
and the work of his hands we may say are
properly his fur for labor being the
unquestionable property of the laborer.
No Man,
but he can have a right to what is once
joined to at least where there is enough
as good left and common for others.
That Labor Locke says puts a distinction
between him and the common that added
something to them more than nature.
The common mother of all had done
and so they become his private.
Right?
So we have moved here in this one
paragraph from the state of nature,
which he says is common to all,
to a condition of
rudimentary private property,
which we have in our body.
Our person,
which he says also includes,
uh,
the Labor of the body and
the work of the hands,
how we expand our activity,
that Labor,
he says,
which puts something between us and the
common becomes the source of ownership
of things around us.
And that ownership then
in turn becomes a right.
So they become,
he concludes there,
his private right.
Uh,
the source of a right to property.
The natural law as hot as lock,
uh,
seems to be saying,
dictates a right to private property
and it is to secure that right that
governments are ultimately established
in a striking formulation.
Lock tells us that the world was created
in order to be cultivated and improved.
Those who work to improve
and develop nature,
who add to nature through the labor
of their body and work of their hands,
those who develop an improved nature
or the true benefactors of humanity,
of,
of human kindness.
God gave the world two men in common.
He says,
section 34,
God gave the world two men in common,
but since he gave it to them for their
benefit and the greatest conveniences of
life that they were
capable to draw from it,
he writes,
the world was given for our convenience.
It says to be drawn from
it cannot be supposed.
He meant it should always remain common
and uncultivated and then he adds,
he gave it to the use of the industrious
and the rational and not to the fancy
or covetousness of the quarrelsome and
contentious God gave the world for our
improvement of it.
And therefore he gave
it to the industrious.
And the rational
lock seems to suggest in that very phrase
that the state will be a commercial
state,
that the Lockian republic or the Lockian
state will be a commercial republic.
Think of that ancient political theory,
Plato,
Aristotle regarded commerce,
regarded a property is in many ways
subordinate to the life of the citizen.
Plato would have instituted a
kind of communism of property,
uh,
among the guardians of his calypso.
Aristotle regarded the necessity thought,
thought of the necessity
of private property,
but simply as a means to allow a few those
citizens to engage in political life.
Economy,
uh,
you might say,
was always subordinate to the polity.
Lock turns this doctrine,
this ancient and medieval
doctrine is well on its head.
In many ways.
The world belongs to the
industrious and the rational.
Those who through their own efforts,
through their labor and
work increase and enhance,
uh,
the plenty of all,
it is only a relatively short step
from John Locke to Adam Smith in that
respect.
The great author of the wealth of nations,
again about a century after,
just under a century after
Locke's second treatise for lock.
And let me just go on a
little more about this.
There are no natural limits to property
acquisition and this is in a way the
essential point,
the introduction of money or coinage
into the state of nature issue.
I'm not going to talk much about here,
but that becomes an important moment in
his chapter five in his account of the
state of nature.
The introduction,
the introduction of money makes
unlimited capital accumulation,
not only possible,
but even a kind of moral duty.
It becomes our duty to enhance and work
upon the raw materials of the natural
world around us.
By enriching ourselves.
We unintentionally,
uh,
work for the benefit of others.
Consider the following
remarkable sentence,
a king of a large and
fruitful territory in America.
He says,
feeds lodges and is clad worse
than a day laborer in England.
Uh,
because of course our work,
Locke thinks has,
has enhanced that the
plenty of all in some way,
the creation of a general planted of
a general planty the Commonwealth.
And think of the way in which the
revealing use of that term Commonwealth,
uh,
con,
the wealth of all is do in many ways
to the emancipation of labor from the
previous kinds of moral and political
restrictions imposed upon it by the
ancient philosophical as
well as religious traditions.
Labor becomes four lock the source
of all value and our title two common
ownership and in a remarkable a
rhetorical series of shifts he makes,
not nature but rather human
labor and acquisition,
this source of property and an
unlimited material possessions.
He begins this chapter,
chapter five with the assertion.
Think about it,
that God hath given the
World Two men in common.
Once again suggesting that the original
state is one of common ownership.
He then suggests that every person is the
owner of their own bodies and that one
acquires a title two things to Labor that
we have mixed with that common world,
but what starts as a very,
very modest title to the objects
that we have worked on it.
His example is nothing as simple as
something as sort of simple as picking
apples from a tree.
The act of picking gives us
a title too to the apple,
that very simple,
a rudimentary form of property soon turns
into a full scale explanation of the
rise of property and a kind of market
economy in the state of nature.
Labor accounts,
he tells us for 10 times
the amount of value,
uh,
that is provided by nature alone.
He says it 37 section 37 our labor
enhances the value of nature 10 times,
but he then goes on to add very quickly.
I have here rated the improved land
very low in making its product,
but as one to 10 when it is much nearer
a hundred to one our labor in advances
things a hundred fold.
Shortly later in section 43 he has said,
he says that the value of anything is
improved a thousand fold due to labor.
Again,
what began is that fairly rudimentary
discussion of the origins of private
property at the beginning of section five
chapter five limited by the extent of
our use and spoilage has by the end
of that same chapter you might say,
morphed into an account of large scale
ownership with considerable inequalities
of wealth and possession.
By the end of chapter five there appears
to be almost a direct link between
locks,
dynamic theory of property and chapter
five and James Madison's famous statement
in federalist number 10 that is Madison
says the protection of different,
an unequal faculties of acquiring property
is the first object of government.
Yeah.
It seems to vary.
Lockian proposition in
the federalist lock gives,
in other words to commerce to moneymaking,
to Aquas,
to acquisitiveness a kind of pride of
place and just sort of moral status you
might even call it that.
It never enjoyed in the
ancient and medieval worlds.
The new politics of Lockian of the
Lockian state will no longer be concerned
with glory,
honor through most virtue.
But locking and politics will be sober,
will be pedestrian,
it will be hedonistic
without sublimity or joy lock
is the author of the doctrine.
Did Commerce,
softens manners,
did it makes us less warlike
that it makes us civilized.
Something that reaches its a,
you might say,
highest expression.
In the 20th chapter,
The 20th book of Monto
skews a spirit of the laws.
Commerce does not require us for
lock to spill blood or risk life.
It has solid,
reliable,
thoroughly middle class.
Uh,
in some ways,
lock is the,
again,
the great author of the idea that the
task of government is to protect not just
the rights of property,
but the right to acquire and build upon,
uh,
the property that we already own.
Sorry,
what to end on this note and begin,
uh,
on Wednesday talking a little bit about
what we might call John Locke and the
spirit of capitalism.